people make assumptions all the time
so let's get the record straight if I
was a drug addict
how could I possibly have done all this
I'm Lisa Frank and this madness that you
see and all this excitement started with
me I know that you weren't comfortable
being on camera is there an element to
the secrecy
well the secrecy has worked for so long
like well I come out of the closet I
don't want to disappoint anybody what if
I'm not who they want me to be our look
is really been consistent for 30 years
and people have tried to tell me bright
colors are in you should do pastels and
it's not who I am we are entering the
vault that has all the original our
argument mm-hmm okay I better figure out
how to open it before you film it the
room is fireproof so that we don't use
the original art but look how bright
everything still is we were involved in
the big sticker craze in the 80s then it
went to school supplies because sticker
is an inch to three inches so it was
more fun to get the art bigger
and you can see it says library sample
do not remove that means like it's
probably one of a kind in hindsight we
could have been even smarter like
keeping 12 of everything there are some
things I don't even have it was so
exciting because we were onto something
that no one else was really on to I mean
people thought I had horns coming out of
my head when I would suggest things
early on the buildings more than 300,000
square feet and at one time like every
Bay was filled up with trucks that were
shipping product out of here in the
beginning we probably had 30 artists at
one time unfortunately now we don't need
as many people in the art department
because things are much easier on the
computer so you now are doing only
licensing right now what we do is we do
the artwork for a whole bunch of other
companies who are then making it and
shipping it I don't think I ever want to
be a manufacturer again that takes away
from Who I am and what I really love to
do is to do our work we want to round
out his face a little bit so he looks a
little cuter I've obviously learned a
ton over the years but in terms of the
artwork and the process I would say that
hasn't changed at all it was never about
making money it was about making good
product and having fun
you